Lesson number four, authority.
This lesson basically is sort of a response.
It's invoking a response from your students of the,
if the Bible is all that we've said the Bible is so far,
then now what?
Because the Bible clearly has something to say
that's really, really important
and has some authority over our lives.
So now what?
Okay?
So let's start with the storyteller.
The storyteller could be this week
and I would suggest it to be this week a student.
I would ask your students
who has been greatly impacted over the last couple of weeks.
I would ask your students like,
hey, who has really just like their mind completely blown
and needs to like just get it off their chest
about what this means because now they're gonna have
a changed life moving in the direction that God desires.
And maybe that's in connection with a retreat
or a specific moment in their life.
But if you've got a student like that,
then I would highly encourage you to utilize that
because what happens in these kinds of moments
is that it's really easy for an adult to say,
this book is important, you should follow it.
Well, they're still learning this book
as many of us are as well.
And it's hard for them to really grasp like,
okay, well, what parts do I follow and how do I follow
and what's literal and what's not.
There's just so many other things here
that they often look at us adults as like,
yeah, but you've got it figured out and you can do it.
And I don't need that right now.
I'm young and I can do what I want.
And when I'm your age, maybe I'll do that.
And I get that it's important and I'll get there.
It's more powerful if one of their peers stands up
and declares based on the evidence,
based on what we've studied,
based on the conviction of the Holy Spirit,
I believe this book to be authoritative
and I'm going to respond in that way
and make sure my life is headed down the path
that God wants it to go.
That's a powerful, powerful statement
and a powerful storyteller
if they can sort of recall like how that happened.
And you might have other students
and maybe that is happening to them
and they just either don't realize it
or aren't willing to speak up about it,
that might conjure up some other feelings
from some other students
and give you a little bit of a gauge where you're at.
If you don't have a student,
then I would suggest that that's in that space
that maybe you have a graduate,
someone that has gone through your program
and is now in college
and now that things are kind of rolling along
and they've been in college for a little bit of time,
maybe they're starting to experience some things,
maybe they're starting to see the importance
of what's in here,
especially some of the contradictions
they may be hearing on the college campus,
have them come in and talk about the Bible's authority
and fill that storyteller role.
Okay, so we say it all the time
and we hear it all the time, right?
The Bible is the word of God
and what we're saying is that the Bible is inspired.
The Bible is infallible.
The Bible is the word of God.
It's everything in it is absolutely true.
Therefore, it must be authoritative, right?
But what students will often struggle with
and what you'll hear in terms of objections is this,
that the Bible was written by men.
Wait a minute, how can the Bible be authoritative?
And yeah, okay, sure, it can be historical
and okay, yeah, I can fulfill prophecy
and okay, it can be completely accurate
and in some kind of strange way.
But how can it be so authoritative
that we call it the word of God?
That we call it the very commands of God
handed down from him to us
so that we can live the way he has designed us to live
if it was written by men.
How do we know that what Matthew recorded
when he recorded the words of Jesus
that he actually recorded the words of Jesus?
I mean, I probably wouldn't get it right.
I was listening to our sermon just on Sunday
and I tried to write down exactly what the pastor said
because I really liked what he said
in one particular sentence
and I couldn't remember exactly what he said in that moment.
How could we expect Matthew to write down everything
that Jesus said perfectly?
These are the kinds of objections
that you will get from your students.
And it's not a terribly difficult objection to deal with
but just to kind of paint the picture for you
the way I've done it with students in the past
is that think of it this way.
And I'm not making an exact equation
but it helps paint a better picture.
Is you have Jesus and you have the Bible.
Now clearly we don't treat the Bible
the same way we treat Jesus.
However, we very easily say that Jesus is 100% man
and he's also 100% God.
Now wait a minute, if I can comfortably say that
why can't I comfortably say that the Bible was written
by men inspired by God to be completely accurate?
See if God can make this sort of thing happen
God can make this sort of thing happen.
It's pretty simple.
The second objection that you'll have to hear students
make is that the Bible may be accurate and historical
in all of those things
but the Bible is simply a book about God
that it's man's recordings of who God is
or who they thought him to be.
Now that's not accurate either
because if the Bible is authoritative
then sure what we think about God
but it was completely accurate
about who God actually is
because otherwise we don't know then who God really is
but we do know who God really is because he came in Jesus
so we actually do have that picture.
So this is so your students start to see
that although it seems very easy
to say other things about the Bible
which really just allows us to excuse ourselves
on various types of sin
that what the Bible teaches is 100% authoritative.
So in your small groups
as you're thinking through all these things
think through the implications of what all of this means.
These last four weeks what all of this is coming
what conclusions are your students now coming to?
And I want to remember three specific things
that your students can understand
to know truth through all of this
is that one they should have a greater appreciation
for this, right?
So if nothing else
they should have a greater appreciation for the Bible
what it says, what it teaches, how it came together
all of those pieces
and hopefully we'll compel them to read a little bit more.
Secondly, that they'll be more inclined to read this.
How many Christians have read the Bible cover to cover
multiple times?
It's the greatest book,
greatest, biggest selling best selling book
in the history of the world
probably the least read book in the history of the world.
And I think they're more likely to follow.
The more they appreciate the more they'll read
the better they'll follow.
That is the aim of this week.
Now, this has to sort of cross into
we're gonna start talking in the next few weeks here
about what this means in conversation.
When your students are in college
when your students are talking with friends
and it might be sitting reading this
and someone makes a comment.
How do they then defend
and talk intelligently about this biblical text?
And I think over the last four weeks
we've been able to provide the tools
that our students need
to be able to talk intelligently
about what this book is all about.